I have just begun taking 10,000 I use a vitamin D daily.
Last, I had a check, but two months ago, my level was 55.
I live in Iowa and I'm getting virtually no sunshine.
How often should I get my level checked?
Well, if your vitamin D level is 55, that is certainly not high.
So on taking 10,000 a day, is that dangerous?
None of your vitamin D level is 55.
If your vitamin D level was 155 in your taking 10,000 a day,
I'd be the first to tell you to decrease your dosage.
There's nothing wrong with 155 vitamin D level.
Still, I think there's any danger in that, but you certainly don't need to be taking 10,000.
So when should you get your vitamin D level checked again?
If two months ago, it was 55 and you just started taking 10,000,
or I would say a couple months.
However, I would say you probably should be getting blood work more often than that.
So if they're going to do blood work to test CBC levels and complete metabolic panel,
why not ask for a vitamin D level?
I mean, literally it's $3 and up to that test.
So every time you get blood work, just ask for a vitamin D level.